- I get slightly freaked out
when I hug and my arms are showing
'cause they put makeup
on me and I'm like, Ugh.
So I don't usually
- Oh, if it's on the outfit.
- Yeah. I don't usually
hug awkward like that.
Like Just with my palms.
Like it was really interesting.
- Well, I thought it was a nice hug.
- It was a nice hug.
- It's nice to be hugging.
- You're here in person.
- Yes.
- Last time it was virtual
Or the first time it was virtual, yeah.
- Yeah. Well, what I gotta say about that
is your setup during
virtual was so impressive.
- Oh.
- Your place in Montana.
That whole room you did.
- Okay. But you only saw
where I was shooting.
So the rest of the house wasn't
it was still being done, so.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, okay. Interesting.
- So I was just in the cold,
like there's no, there's
no was no heating yet.
There was nothing.
It was just in a corner
and it looked like I had my together.
- Well, from my view, it looked so good
and I was in my closet.
- Yeah, you were.
- So I was, that was.
- A lot of people were.
- Yeah, but it was so embarrassing.
Yours had like this
behind it, it looked like.
- Yeah.
- Mine had my wife's dresses.
- Oh wait. You know what?
No, no, no.
I might have talked to you.
I was like, wait, I did
do something from Montana.
and then I also did some
from here where they did build like a set.
- That's the thing I think I saw.
- No, that's the thing. I didn't do that.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
No, but I did shoot
some of the show from my
a cabin that was unfinished in Montana
and we made it look like it.
No. Yeah. They built
that, my art department.
- Oh okay. 'Cause that's what I saw
and that's what I was in.
(audience laughs)
We were talking, I'm like, oh yeah.
They're like, it's gonna be casual.
I'm like great. I'm
like, no, mine is casual.
- Yeah. This is not
casual. This is not casual.
- There's like literal dresses.
- No, they came in and it was so funny
because I had to leave my house.
- Right.
- Just because of COVID law.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You couldn't, I couldn't
be in the house with them.
So only like one person
could come in and build.
It was like crazy.
- It was insane.
- But I walked back into
my formal living room
and I was like there's
a set in my living room.
It was weird.
- Which is trippy.
- I love the shoe thing though
that you had. The shoe thing.
- Yeah. I did not want it on TV.
I didn't think about it
- It was awesome.
Everybody though.
That's what's so funny. We
got to see everyone's closet.
For some reason that was
where everyone was hiding
from their children.
- (laughs) Yeah, exactly right.
- So I heard you took
advantage of the pandemic
and you did like some at home stuff.
You built something.
- Yeah. Well partly
'cause of stuff like that.
- Where I was like
- You felt the shamed
- I felt shamed. And I
was like I need a spot
'cause you know, we had no idea
how long the pandemic was gonna go.
- Yeah.
- So I was like,
so I needed an office.
I needed it in my backyard and
I wasn't sure how to do it.
So I looked at YouTube clips.
- You can learn everything on YouTube
- Dude. It blew my mind.
- Yes.
- I learned everything.
- Yeah.
- And so I built a cabin.
I was doing a lot of the zooms from there.
- You built a cabin?
You built that?
- I built that.
(audience applauds)
- What!
- Totally. From YouTube.
Everything from framing
- You need like an HGTV show.
(Jake laughs)
- Yeah.
- I think people are like
making sourdough bread,
and making like small bird
box feeders or something.
- Totally.
- You made an actual cabin.
- Yeah. It was great.
Now what you don't see in the photos
is the amount of ants and
spiders that live in there.
- Yeah.
- And how hot it gets.
- You just have to pretend you're camping.
- That's what it is.
It's camping nonstop.
But I put it up.
It was great.
It's been great.
And then when summer hit,
it was the first time I'm like,
oh yeah, this is a sauna.
- Oh.
- I built an ant house and a sauna.
- Especially if you live
in the Valley, which I do.
Yeah. I thought Texas was hot.
The Valley here is like
a different level of,
I hate my life.
Yeah. Yeah.
- But what I will say from
doing a little zoom in there
to this.
This is so nice.
(audience applauds)
- I think it's impressive
that you built that.
- It was really fun.
- Do do your kids love that?
My kids would go nuts over that.
- You know, they don't
because I mean the trick is
just throw a couple
spiders and ants in a spot.
- Oh.
- And kids have no interest.
- So now I know what to do.
- Yes.
So it really, I was like
okay. So I built this
- I'm gonna line them up in
front of my room at home.
- Everything you like, one big spider.
- Just to deter them.
- That's right.
- This is good advice.
I have to ask you about this
because I feel like so
many people come on here
and have a Prince story and I
know Prince was on New Girl.
So what do you have a
story? A Prince story.
- Yeah. Well I know, well
Prince really liked New Girl
which was cool.
- Yeah.
- We found out that he watches
- Like a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Like, liked it, yeah.
- I'm like Prince is a wild like.
And so he wanted to do it, the show.
He, you know, obviously Liz Meriwether
then said like, come on.
- Yeah.
And when he came and
he was walking around.
He was talking to Zoe and
he was kind of where you are
and I'm here.
And then I saw him look at me
and he said to Zoe, "I would
like to meet Nick now."
- Oh, he called you Nick?
- And Zoe looked at me and
obviously whatever Prince wants.
So she looked at I'm like, yeah.
So she walked in and she's like,
"Hey, Nick, come over here."
And I was like, "Hey".
And I met Prince and he
was as nice as it gets.
And he wanted to live in the reality
of the show and he wanted
Nick and Jess to be together.
So he said he'll do the show
if he could help them get together
and he got to live a little fantasy.
- Wait, he changed the
narrative of the story?
I love that.
- He wanted them together.
And we wanted Prince.
- Prince was so powerful.
- Prince is, I mean the best.
- What kind of power is that?
Yes. But I need them to get together.
I will not show up.
- Because I'm happy to do it.
If I'm part of them being together.
- Oh my gosh.
- The best.
- Did he call you Nick the whole time?
- Honestly, I was in, I'm such a fan.
that I think he also could
have called me anything
and I would've responded.
- John.
- He could have called me
"shut up and gave me my coffee"
and I'd be like, you got it.
It didn't matter.
- Absolutely.
- Absolutely sir.
- I love that he was like,
wouldn't do it unless they would.
That's amazing.
So that was the look at his show.
His HBO Max show, Minx.
The show is very funny.
It's very clever.
But for those who haven't seen it
and need a little bit
more than in your face,
what's it about?
(Jake and Kelly laugh)
- Shvantz in the face.
So it's basically about the creation
of like a Playgirl
magazine in the seventies.
It's a young feminist, has an idea
for a magazine and meets a
smut publisher who I play.
- Yeah.
- And we create Minx together
and we launch it and we sell it.
And the cast is incredible.
The writing's great.
It's a really, really fun show.
And if you can get past
the shvantzes in the face.
- I think you're gonna love it.
- Or if you watch it for that reason
- Whatever, however you wanna watch it.
- There's an audience for everyone.
- That's exactly right.
- I love that you're playing
this character though.
Is it fun to play someone so outrageous?
- It is. He's a great character.
Ellen Rappaport, writer, has created
like such a fun, unique person.
And you know, so the funny thing is
when she was courting me for this job.
You know, it's about the
seventies and Playgirl.
And so she sent me some Playgirls.
- So that's a good way to
get someone in. (laughs)
- Well, you know,
- You wanna see a bunch of
- I was like, all right,
here's a bunch of nude men
from the seventies. Cool.
And so I like put 'em on a shelf
and I'm like I don't need to see this.
- Yeah.
- But I did come home one day
and my daughters had found it.
- No.
- And there were these
two girls going like this
Yes. And I had to go like,
"Don't look at that!"
And they go, "Why?"
And I go, "I don't know."
(audience laughs)
- I don't have any reason right now.
- No one's trained me on what to say here,
but I don't think you should look at dudes
from the seventies who are naked.
- Oh my God.
- And so I called Ellen and I said,
"Thank you for that,
but please don't send me
anymore of these magazines."
- I don't need to be method about it.
- Yeah. I don't need it.
I'll just read the scripts.
I'll play the part.
- Oh my gosh. That. What do you.
Yeah, 'cause kids do find
things in your house sometimes.
And the stories that come like
so quickly from your mouth.
You're like, does that even make sense?
Just go with it.
They're young, they don't know.
- Yeah. But I also
didn't know what to say.
'Cause they were like, well you had it
and why do you have it?
And I had to say like, because of my job.
- Yeah. And then your
job seems very messed up.
- So weird. Like what am I gonna say?
Go to bed at nine.
Now my job is I look at
these weird magazines.
- I'm like the authority
is getting really weird.
Just trust me.
- My golden rule, just listen to me.
So wait, is it true that
you've gotten into hypnotherapy
because I have never done it.
I'm afraid to do it, but I wanna do it.
- What are you afraid of?
- I'm afraid that like,
someone's gonna get me
to do something like,
and I'm just not.
It's like I want somebody
else to be in the room
to make sure no one messes with me.
- So you don't end up doing
like the chicken dance.
- Yes.
- You see it at like Vegas.
- I literally said
chicken dance in my head
and I didn't wanna sound weird,
but you did so okay.
- So I have, I found a woman
who's really great at it
and I really like it.
It's not as crazy as those
Vegas shows would tell you.
I don't like start and then I'm
like, anything could happen.
- But why did you do it?
What was your, what was your reasoning?
- I was interested.
I was interested in finding a form
of therapy that just felt different.
- That's my thing.
Like any kind of like
trauma is that like helpful?
- You're able to almost
rewrite your own past.
(Kelly gasps)
So you're able to see an experience
but you're controlling it.
It's not like the hypnotherapist
is guiding you through it.
- Okay.
- So you get to go back
and go like, I would like to rewrite this
and view this moment.
That's probably not that big of a trauma.
Maybe I saw it wrong.
- So its like almost looking it
from a vantage point.
Different vantage point.
- You get to see your past from now,
but you're also making it up a little bit.
- Okay.
- So you can kind of make it more positive
and how you want it to be.
- This is something everyone should do.
- Well, I don't know.
- We all have trauma.
- Totally.
I know that for me I've really loved it.
And the other side is it's really fun.
- Yeah.
- And I think that
if you're doing something for self-help
- Yeah.
- It's also okay to enjoy it.
- Yeah. Okay. You wanna know
something funny? (laughs)
My, my therapist was like,
literally her advice to me
was stop reading self-help
or any educational thing. (laughs)
- How come?
- She was like, you need to stop.
You need to read some kind
of fiction because I obsess
- Read a mystery.
- Just read some Agatha Christie.
She's like, you need to not.
I wanna, next time we talk,
I don't want you to be like,
"so I read this" and it's like
- And I want, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Totally.
- 'Cause I just love like
everyone's perspective on life
and like what they're learning.
I just love knowing what I could learn.
I'm a last born.
So I feel like that's,
I'm used to like kind of
- You watch the older people do it
and then you make your adjustments.
- Yes. We're the perfect
sucker for a self-help book.
- Well, look, I'm talking
about hypnotherapy
on the Kelly Clarkson Show.
- I'm into it though.
I really have wanted to do it
but I want to like trust
the person I'm going to.
So I'm totally gonna get the number. Yeah.
- I find it really fun and I
feel like that's self-help.
So if you're gonna do it,
you might as well enjoy it.
'Cause it's really just
like a weird hobby.
- And it's not. I'm still
obeying what my therapist says.
It's something different.
(Jake and Kelly laugh)
- Yeah, Totally.
It's not a self help book.
And it's like educational things.
I'm just obsessed with them. Anyway.